okay suddenly leaves here and this is
one of the weirdest times to be alive
right now
as a property entrepreneur people are
coming to me saying Samuel what should
we do as a property entrepreneur does
this trade you work is that strategy
work and rather than the answer all your
questions I just had a crazy idea and
I've been I've been mining this over the
last couple days and the point now it's
crazy that wouldn't work and then last
night when I read the newspapers and it
said that we could be in lockdown until
July I just thought you know what forget
it let's do it and the idea was this
because I don't want everyone to be in
the house until July waiting for the
government about not waiting so I just
thought you know what
financial freedom challenge in isolation
in lockdown I don't know how it's gonna
work
I've no idea but and I don't want to do
this alone I want everybody watching
this I want there to be a community of
property entrepreneurs that stand
together the support one another the
talk about the good things the bad
things the opportunities the and let's
try and make money let's try and make
money as property entrepreneurs in
self-isolation from home because I don't
want to encourage people to believe in
the house to be doing these stuff we
could put but at the same time what can
we do from isolation at home so I'm
going to start right now I don't know
what I'm going to do but as soon as I
press end on this video I'm gonna start
going online with my laptop thinking
strategizing calling and trying to just
do some deals I don't wanna make as much
money as I can I'm gonna do as many
probably deals as I can the right kind
of property deals during this quarantine
and I want you to join with me as well
and if you think the idea is crazy
moving is stupid then you can just watch
if you think the ideas kind of got flex
and it kind of is a good idea I want you
to do it with me we can do a hash tag
hash tag proper hash tag lockdown
property challenge that's the hash tag
I'll put it in the in the in the
description to this video
hash tag lockdown property challenge
let's make money that's packaged here
for sale bills let's do as much as we
physically can there's a lot of people
in the world right now in problems
because when there's so much fear and
everyone's not done there's problems
what's the definition of an entrepreneur
and entrepreneur is someone the souls
and then makes money as a resort that
lets be property entrepreneurs let's be
it Jim Rohn says the same wind blows on
us all it's not the wind that determines
the destination is the setting of the
sail right now we're in a storm
absolutely right now crazy things are
happening and crazy things are going to
happen but let's set the sail right and
protect ourselves protect our children
and make sure that we are actually able
to make moving and not having to rely on
anyone nice to rely on the government
not have to rely on employers lock down
property challenge I'm gonna be doing it
I'm gonna be documenting what I'm doing
even if I have to do from my phone from
my laptop in my living room I'm going to
be documenting yet and I'm going to be
sharing you with you exactly what deals
I'm doing exactly how it's going down
and I want to do this as a community I
want to do this as a team so I want you
to upload videos as well make yourself a
YouTube account start uploading your own
videos and talk about what you're doing
you can copy me you can follow me you
can start in your own thing maybe I'll
copy you but let's do this and let's do
it together no negativity just learning
together positivity want to make more
wanting to make a difference in our own
lives and lead the world a better place
than we found it not moan now find
excuses hashtag lock down property
challenge share this video with every
entrepreneur with every property
investor that you know that you want to
see making a difference and stepping out
and taking responsibility share the
video with them right now go let's do
this together